TO ORDER. PLEASE BE ADVISED
THAT AN AUDIO AND VIDEO
RECORDING IS BEING MADE OF
TODAY'S PROCEEDING AND IT ALSO
IT IS ALSO BEING TELEVISED AND
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY CUNNINGHAM CARILLO
HERE FLORA HERE GRAYSON HERE
KAMLAGER MAIENSCHEIN. THIS
PRESENT WORKS OVER HERE FROM
HERE RIVAS WICKS. ONE THANK YOU
WE HAVE A CONSENT WE HAVE A
QUORUM WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA
IS OUR MOTION ON THE SECOND WAS
A MOTION AND A SECOND MOTION
FOR MATHIS AND FROM WICKS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CUNNINGHAM CARILLO. YES CARILLO
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLOOR AYE
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE CAN
WATER KAMLAGER MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE MATHIS MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA HI QUIRK SILVA
AYE RUN MUCH TIME RAMOS I RIVAS
ON CONSENT. RIVERSIDE WORKS
FINE WORKS FINE. NUMBER IS
PASSED. WE WILL HOLD THE ROLE
OPEN. OKAY WE CAN ADJOURN.
SORRY.